los adolescentes franceses tendrán que
presentar ahora el pase sanitario si
quieren acceder a diferentes lugares y
eventos públicos estarán en las mismas
condiciones que los mayores de 18 años
así lo anunció el ministerio de salud
francés a partir del 30 de septiembre el
pase sanitario entré en vigor para los
jóvenes entre los 12 años y los meses y
los 17 años pida su cita para vacunarse
a través de un código digital los
adolescentes deben mostrar un
comprobante de salud que acredite ya sea
la vacunación contra el coi 19 una
prueba negativa de menos de 72 horas o
un certificado de recuperación del
coronavirus que no supere los 6 meses en
los días previos al anuncio cientos de
estudiantes en parís y otras ciudades
fueron vacunados en sus escuelas con el
fin de que no tengan inconvenientes para
ir a lugares o eventos públicos
[Música]
como hoy me vacuné primero para poder
volver a salir a restaurantes con mis
amigos
para poder ir a fiestas con ellos
y
también para viajar ya sea el extranjero
o en francia y para poder participar en
actividades al aire libre
desde exhibida el exterior pero aún son
muchos los franceses que se resisten
miles de personas siguen manifestando
durante los fines de semana contra el
fasi sanitario y también la vacunación
obligatoria como es el caso para muchos
empleados de los servicios de salud este
miércoles el gobierno francés anunció su
intención de extender el pasaporte
sanitario hasta mediados de 2022
mientras continúa su campaña de
vacunación que ya superó la barrera de
los 50 millones de personas que han
recibido al menos una dosis del antígeno